HIREN PATEL: Hello,
and welcome, everyone,
to the Google Developers
Africa Hangout, episode 3.
On the panel today,
we have a couple
of GDEs-- Google
Developer Experts--
as well as some
Googlers as well.
Just to remind you
about the GDE program,
it is a program that is
open to all developers.
It involves two
basic requirements--
a technical expertise
in a certain product
or technology from
Google, and a passion
to share this technology
with other developers locally
or in the community around you.
So as a benefit of
this, you basically
get support for your
activities from Google,
speaking at conferences
and the like.
You also get a close
relationship with Google.
As a big benefit
of this program,
especially for me, is that we
have quite a close relationship
with some technical
leads at Google.
And as we know, Google is
at the forefront of pushing
technologies in web and mobile.
We get good access to
this amount of information
and experience out of this.
So just to remind you, this
show is a monthly show.
We try to run it
as often as we can.
We provide it as
a recorded video
for viewing afterwards as well.
We provide a
downloadable mp3 as well.
The show is theme based.
So we pick a theme,
we discuss the theme,
and then we take some
questions on this.
So if you have any
specific themes
that you'd like us to
cover in some episodes,
please reach out to
us and let us know.
So I'm going to hand
it over to GDE Kenneth
to introduce the panel
some more for us.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: Hi, everyone.
So welcome to this show.
First of all, I'm
going to introduce
the panel, which comprises of
a couple of GDEs and Googlers.
First up is Johann
du Toit, who's
a cloud GDE from Cape
Town, so he raise his hand.
We also have Hiren Patel,
a cloud GDE from Cape Town.
We have Dale Humby, also a cloud
GDE from Cape Town, and myself.
We have Mercy Orangi, who's the
developer ecosystem community
manager for sub-Saharan
Africa, and she's
more focused on the
Google Launchpad program.
We have Charles Odili, who's
a Googler based in the Nigeria
office.
We have Liz Yespen,
who's also a Googler,
and she's been supporting
this show since the start.
As since Hiren told us that
this show is theme based,
this show will focus
on material design,
and specifically, we'll be
talking about material design
on the web with
Material Design Lite.
So we always have a
spotlight segment,
and this show, we will have
Charles Odili on the spotlight.
We'll also be taking a couple of
questions after Hiren presents,
and also we will be
closing up and wrapping up.
So I'd like to jump into the
spotlight section with Charles.
So hi, Charles.
Could you tell us
about yourself?
CHARLES ODILI: My
name is Charles Odili.
And I am a Google [INAUDIBLE]
in the Lagos office in Nigeria.
Before joining Google,
I was a web developer
for five or six years with
the University of Benin
and University of
Lagos in Nigeria.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: OK, Charles.
So could you tell us your
current role at Google,
and what you actually focus on?
CHARLES ODILI: OK.
So I'm the Google
developer community
manager for sub-Saharan Africa,
the same team that Mercy.
Mercy's based in
the Kenya office,
and I'm based in
the Nigeria office.
I'm basically focused
on developer communities
in sub-Saharan Africa,
including GDGs.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: Wow.
Awesome.
So you mentioned GDGs.
Could you tell us a
little bit about GDGs,
since we've been hearing about
them, and some of the events
that they have in the community?
CHARLES ODILI: Yeah.
So GDG stands for
Google Developer Group,
and they are groups
or communities
of developers, who share like
minds, share passion, come
together, meet from time to
time, to learn and share ideas,
collaborate, and therefore,
improve their skill from one
level to the other.
These communities now
spread across several cities
in different countries
across sub-Saharan Africa.
We currently have
over 100 of them,
and they have very well spread.
So we have several
in major cities,
not like [INAUDIBLE]
is a non-major anyway,
but yeah, most of the
major cities in Africa
have a GDG [INAUDIBLE], and they
are communities of developers.
I would encourage
everyone to participate
in the community effort
that's going on in Africa.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: OK.
So there's been a little
buzz on Google+ with the GDGs
especially, something
about the DevFest series,
and I've also been seeing
a couple of hashtags going
through about the
Google developer kits.
Could you tell us something
about what the DevFest
series is all about,
and maybe also mention
what the Google developer
offline kits are all about.
CHARLES ODILI: Yeah, sure.
So the GDGs have several events.
They have meet-offs, they
have code lab sessions,
they have tech calls,
they have hackathons,
they have study jams.
A very big part of this event
series are called the DevFest.
So the DevFests are
generally larger GDG events
that involve, like, hands-on
and deep-dive sessions, where
developers can have
the opportunity
to get their hands
dirty on code,
get their hands on the latest
technologies from Google
or from other open
source initiatives.
The DevFest series are starting
about now, through November,
goes the group, and the same
thing's happening with SSE.
So we are seeing
several DevFests
across several GDGs
in sub-Saharan Africa.
We encourage developers to join
these events for an opportunity
to, like, get your hands dirty
on the latest Google techology.
KENNETH KINJANJUI:
You're killing me.
CHARLES ODILI: In
line with that,
we also have the
offline developer kits,
the initiative from Google to
help the African developer make
the most of technologies,
irrespective of the challenges
that we have in Africa,
including power and internet.
So the average developer,
or most developers,
who have challenges
of internets can
route through the
offline developer kit,
because the packages
offline, packages
contains including
SDKs, including APIs,
including documentation.
It brings all of these
from the internet
and puts them in a digital
format, like, on a CD
and on a USB, such that the
developer will have access
to these resources,
and they can learn,
they can watch the
videos, they can
view the accordion
without necessarily
having to be online.
This keeps available right
now through the GDGs.
And we encourage developers
to join these communities
and avail themselves of the
opportunity if they're offline.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: OK.
Charles, since you started
working with Google
and working with GDGs,
what's your view on what you
experience from GDG
members or developers
in sub-Saharan Africa in the
next couple of months or one
year?
CHARLES ODILI: OK, so
a lot has been going on
in GDGs for some time now,
particularly this year,
for example, [INAUDIBLE] would
be the study jams [INAUDIBLE]
that allowed GDGs to
have a series of events
on other development.
Some GDGs [INAUDIBLE]
study jams.
[INAUDIBLE] too.
And we also have
put in [INAUDIBLE]
let's say, the hands-on
deep dive series of events,
so in the coming months, up to,
let's say, the next one year,
we expect our developers
to have better skills,
have more experience, to
have collaborated more.
We expect to see more apps
on the [INAUDIBLE], even
those who already
have apps, we expect
them to improve these
apps with the APIs
on the technology [INAUDIBLE],
from all these events
[INAUDIBLE].
So we can expect more apps, and
we expect more polished apps
from the GDGs.
Yeah.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: Also, coming
up from a web development
background, as you mentioned,
at the University of Benin,
what's your viewpoint
on Material Design Lite?
CHARLES ODILI: So Material
Design Lite is a great library.
I love it.
I've used it a couple
of times on projects.
Material design is the new
design language from Google,
and Material Design Lite
has helped me to implement
material design on my projects.
So I love it, and I encourage
developers to embrace it,
because it will give them cool
new experiences in their apps.
It works really good now.
Go check it out.
KENNETH KINJANJUI:
That's amazing.
So now we will be jumping to
the main session, where we'll
be having Hiren taking us
through material design
on the web using
Material Design Lite.
Hiren.
HIREN PATEL: Thank you
very much, Kenneth.
So I'm just going to
quickly share my screen.
All right.
So material design-- quite an
exciting design spec or design
language by Google.
The full spec of the language
is at design.google.com,
and pretty much, in a
nutshell, in this presentation,
if you look to the
screenshot on the right,
material design involves using
complementing in bold colors,
a beautiful typography,
supporting elements,
as well as floating
elements-- floating papers--
and it brings together all
these elements of the UI
into one user experience
that's meant to,
at the end of the
day, make the user
experience for this specific
app, or this specific page,
really beautiful.
So it combines the different
elements, and interactions
between the elements, to give
the user a beautiful user
experience.
So you're encouraged to
see the entire design
spec at design.google.com.
We've see material
design before, mostly
on Android up till now.
And over here, you can
see in the screenshots,
the bold colors, the beautiful
typography, in the calculator
app for Android.
In the last screenshot,
that's a dialer app,
and you can see the beautiful
call to action floating
button for the hang-up there.
And so this is what
material design is about.
It's about making a
really beautiful user
interface and
interactions for the app,
and giving your user a beautiful
experience as a result.
So this is great on Android,
and so I asked myself,
if I were to build a
new user interface,
be it on Android
or anything else,
why would I use
material design and how?
And the first
thing to note there
is that material design
is not just for Android.
Even though you primarily
see it on Android today,
it's not locked into
the platform in any way.
In fact, Google is
pushing huge efforts
into making it
available on the web.
But you can use material
design pretty much anywhere
you need a beautiful
user experience, really.
So another reason
I would use it is
that Google has whole teams
doing research around user
experience and user interfaces.
For me, as a small developer
team or a lone developer,
I would rather leverage
off this research
that's already been done and
not have to do it myself.
Another reason is the
tooling is also done for me,
so on Android in the
form of libraries,
and these days on the web in
the form of material design
libraries as well,
you're not having
to bold the elements and parts
of the UI manually yourself,
There's libraries that
give you this already,
so a lot of the tooling
is done for you.
And pretty much the main reason
I would use material design
in a user interface
these days is
to give the user a
beautiful experience.
Even if you're a lone
developer or have a small team,
you're now able to give users an
amazing experience, leveraging
not just the tools, but
all the research that
comes behind material design.
So what options do we
have when we're looking
at material design for the web?
There's Polymer,
which we've heard of,
and Polymer's been having
material design elements
for a while now,
although Polymer includes
a lot of new web
technology as well,
and Polymer is about more
than just material design.
Polymer's also a fairly large
component, and sort of not
as easy to integrate
into smaller new apps
compared to other libraries
that are out there.
So the next one--
and a really nice one
to get into, if you're starting
out-- is Material Design Lite.
And so this is a library
provided by Google--
open source as well.
The library, firstly, depends
on no JavaScript framework
as such, so it's a
really light library
and doesn't depend on anything.
It is optimized for
cross-device use, which
is really important these days.
With mobile being really
important within Africa itself,
you definitely want
to use something
that's optimized for mobile.
It degrades gracefully
in all the browsers,
so it doesn't break.
And it offers an immediately
accessible experience
starting out with
material design, which
was quite important for me.
So what do you get with
Material Design Lite?
Firstly, everything
you need to know
is at www.getmdl.io-- the
documentation lives there,
the example, the
templates, and everything
pretty much getting started.
And what you get by
using this library
is new UI controls that
conform to material design.
So these are check boxes,
buttons, and the usual controls
you're used to in
HTML already, that
have been sort of revamped to
conform to the material design
spec.
But you also get some
specialized features--
among them are cards, column
layouts, sliders, spinners,
and some beautiful typography.
But what else do you
get with this library?
You get some templates, with
GitHub links to the templates,
so if you're needing to
adjust the templates,
they can be done easily.
And let me show you quickly
what some of these templates
look like.
So over on the MDL--
www.getmdl.io--
there's some
templates for a blog.
We have some templates before
dashboards, text heavy web
pages, and standalone articles.
So you can leverage some
of these templates as well.
So you also get a theme builder.
Material design is about
using a primary color
and a supporting accent
color in your UI,
and they make it really easy
to choose these colors well.
So if you head over to
www.getmdl.io, one of the links
is around customizing
your theme.
And so you'll pick
a primary color,
you'll pick a
supporting accent color,
and you can see to the
right of the screenshot,
as I pick my colors,
this basically
changes to show me what
my UI might look like.
And lastly, there's a really
active and vibrant GitHub
and StackOverflow community
around this project,
or this library.
So if you get stuck or you
have any issues around this,
be sure to check out
the GitHub issues link.
Be sure to check StackOverflow
for the project as well.
So let's look at a simple
example for Material Design
Lite.
I was chatting to
a friend recently
who was looking to build
a simple web survey,
and I thought, why
don't I throw together
a simple web survey for him.
It was regarding a
product at a store,
so I thought, why not just have
a mock survey around avocados
at a store called MyStore.
And so I began to put
together a simple web survey
for him using Material
Design Lite to see what this
could come out and look like.
So there were two
requirements from him on this.
The first is that it needs
to be mobile friendly, mostly
because the primary
audience for this
was going to be mobile
users, and it must offer
a beautiful user experience.
So there are many survey tools
and web frameworks out there.
This needs to sort
of set itself apart
by giving a better
or a more beautiful
user experience as such.
So in doing this, I used
a couple of the components
from the Material
Design Lite library.
Some of these are cards,
the drawer-- which I only
wanted on smaller screens--
then I used the slider on one
of the questions, I used the
radio box, check box, and text
boxes for other
questions, and then
I used the button for
the submit of the survey.
So let's quickly have a look
at what this looks like.
And basically, my page
came out to look like this.
You can see that I've
got a question per card.
I then have a header at the top.
I have some links on
the header to the right.
I've used the controls
within each card,
so I've used the slider, I've
used the radio boxes, the check
boxes, et cetera.
And then just to show you
how this is sort of geared
toward any screen size, if I
minimize this window for you,
you will see how the elements
sort of arrange themselves
nicely.
So we can see that, firstly, the
links on the header are gone,
and they folded into a drawer,
which I can access by clicking
on the hamburger icon.
Each of my cards has
folded to, , basically,
settle one beneath each other.
And just to quickly show
you what these elements are
like in material design, if
you click around on the slider,
you can see that it animates
in a really beautiful way.
If I click on the
radio box, you can
see that there's a beautiful
ripple effect on the radio box.
The same goes for
the check boxes.
And you can see
that it's conforming
to the color of
the theme as well.
You can see on the text box that
the hint text sort of floats
beautifully to the
top as I click it,
and then the button sort of
gives you the material design
ripple.
So it's worth noting that all
these work on touch as well
as normal web clicks as well.
So this is what it
turned out to be like.
And I'm going to
walk you through what
I needed to do to, basically,
get that page running
in the way that it looks.
So firstly, every
HTML page, you will
need to include four things.
The first one is the CSS file
based on your choice of colors
for the material design UI.
The second one is
the JavaScript file.
It is pretty small, as
you know the library's
built to be light.
The third one is the
material design icons,
which are open source icons
for you to make use of,
and the last one is
the viewport metatag,
which is really important
to enable this to work
across different screen sizes.
So the first thing I did
after putting those four in
is getting some sort
of layout together.
And what I did here
was, of course,
so I needed to put
a header in there,
and Material Design
Lite gives you
choices of a couple of headers,
so you can have a scrolling
header, a fixed header,
a header that always
has the nav bar shown, so on.
So I've picked the
fixed header over here,
which means if I scroll,
the header stays there.
And you can have as many
header rows within the header
as you want as well.
So the next thing I
did was define a grid.
And over here, all I
did was-- I have a div,
and I've given it a
CSS class of mdl-grid.
And material design grids
work sort of in the same way
that Bootstrap grids work.
You have 12 columns,
and as you shrink
the size of the screen
in terms of the width,
the columns decrease
to eight and four.
And so what I've
got here is I've
defined my cells being
four columns wide,
which is why, on a large screen,
I have three cards in a row.
If I reduce this, it goes
down to two and one card.
So the next thing I have is,
in every cell, I've got a div,
and I've turned
the div into a card
by putting some CSS classes
on here-- mdl-card-- which
we can see in the
third line of the code,
and that gives me
the card affect
you see on the
screenshot on the right.
So in some of the cards I've
used the different elements
from-- the control
elements from the library,
and here I'm just inserting
a CSS class called mdl-slider
on my input element, and you'll
see that this, basically,
provides me with a beautiful
slider and the animations
on the slider we saw.
This is the radio buttons.
Here again, as well,
the input element
simply has a class
of mdl-radio_button.
The label for the radio
has a class of mdl-radio,
and this sort of gets
them to work together
in the material design
way, and gives them
the ripple effect as well.
So for the rippling,
you'll see I've got
the mdl-js-ripple-effect of
CSS class on this element.
With the checkboxes, it's
pretty much the same story.
I've just got mdl-checkbox
on my label as a CSS class,
and for my input box, I've
got mdl-checkbox_input.
And for my input box, I've
also just assigned some classes
to the CSS--
mdl-textfield-- and you
can see that in the hint there,
I've got mdl-textfield_label.
So pretty much the common
thing you've seen from this
is that this library
pretty much involves
you putting CSS classes in
your already built-up elements
to give them this material
design effect and look,
and this is how easy and
what the library's all about.
There's nothing
fancy involved, it's
just a matter of
putting the classes
within your already
defined elements
to give you these effects.
So here I've got
the button-- again,
a simple button--
and I've given it
mdl-button and the
mdl-js ripple classes,
and this turns it into a
rippling material design
button.
So at the end of this,
this is what I have.
On the full screen page, it
looks with three cards per row.
The moment you shrink that
down to the mobile size,
it arranges beautifully
in a single column.
And lastly, some resources.
So you will get started
at www.getmdl.io.
The frequently asked
questions page on that site
has some really interesting
stuff for beginning out.
I found it quite useful.
And then the GitHub
and StackOverflow pages
are really useful as well.
If you run into
any issues, I think
those are the first places you
would go and have a look for.
And that pretty much
wraps up the presentation.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: Thank
you very much, Hiren,
for that awesome presentation.
So we'll be taking
questions, and we'll
have Dale and Johann answering,
and monitoring questions
from live attendants.
You can post your questions on
the Q&A that's on the right.
On Google+ as well.
DALE HUMBY: While we wait
for-- sorry, Johann--
while we wait for some of
those questions to come in,
I wanted to know from Hiren,
how big is the library?
I know some of these frameworks
and libraries get quite big.
How much is it going to add
to my page if I put this on?
Bearing in mind,
though, I'm probably
going to be using this
on my mobile device,
I don't want it to
charge too much.
HIREN PATEL: Yep.
So it touts itself
as a light library,
and so I've looked into this,
and the three pieces you need
are the CSS, the JS, and
the icons, and combined,
they work out to under
30 kilobytes in size.
And I found that once I had them
and they were cached, it was,
that was that, so really small.
Under 30 kilobytes in total.
DALE HUMBY: OK.
That's great.
Thank you.
JOHANN DU TOIT: So
question from me on that,
is do you need the
entire libraries,
or is it a framework
that you use
one shot just in
the entire thing,
or can you use parts of it?
HIREN PATEL: Yeah.
So it wasn't designed
to be split into pieces
and selected by piece.
Pretty much,
there's three pieces
you need-- it's, as
I mentioned, the CSS
file, the JS, and the icons,
and that's the entire library,
so you wouldn't
pick pieces of it.
You would include
those three, and you
get the entire--
everything it has to offer.
DALE HUMBY: And can we
use Material Design Lite
on our mobile apps?
HIREN PATEL: Yes,
most definitely.
So one of the main
goals of the library
was to allow sort of
a seamless experience
across different screen sizes,
and we saw from the demo
that as I shrunk the size,
everything folded over
beautifully, so one
of the main cases
is being able to use this
across different screen
sizes and different devices.
It'll support all the latest
browsers, up to two versions
back, and it will
gracefully degrade
on older browsers, so a definite
yes for mobile use cases
as well.
DALE HUMBY: OK.
That's fantastic.
JOHANN DU TOIT: OK.
So we have a question in on
the live page, from Gary.
So for Angular apps,
should we continue
to use Angular Material, or
would you recommend to use MDL?
HIREN PATEL: So
from my perspective,
if you're already
using Angular Material,
I would continue using that.
I think Material
Design Lite is meant
to be something really simple
and easy to get started out
with on material
design, and I see
it more as a library you would
use in a framework that's not
doing material design
already that you
want to incorporate it into.
JOHANN DU TOIT: Thank you.
Dale?
DALE HUMBY: How
easy is it to change
the colors of the branding?
HIREN PATEL: So
that's really simple.
I'm going to quickly show
you via screen share.
The page provided
on the www.getmdl.io
will allow you to
customize this.
So this is the
customization page
for the primary and the
supporting accent color.
And you can see
here that if I've
chosen two colors--
firstly, as mentioned,
it does update the
UI to the right
so you can immediately
see what it is,
and the moment you like
that, it puts the HTML link
tag at the bottom here for you.
So all you would need to do is,
once you're happy with the UI,
you take the link tag and copy
and paste that into your HTML,
and you get the new look.
So really simple.
DALE HUMBY: Thank you.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: We also have
another question that has just
come from Moey from Niger.
So she asks, how is the theme
sets for the different colors?
HIREN PATEL: How
is the theme set?
KENNETH KINJANJUI: Yes.
HIREN PATEL: So
once you've chosen
the primary and the
supporting accent color,
basically, your UI will
conform to the spec as such,
so in any cases where the spec
is using the primary color,
your UI is going to
use the primary color,
and in cases where it's
using the supporting colors,
it would use that.
So it's going to
apply your primary
and your supporting color as
per the spec throughout your UI.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: OK.
Thank you.
JOHANN DU TOIT: I think
we have one-- sorry.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: Oh.
We have another question?
JOHANN DU TOIT: Yes.
So just last one probably.
So we know there's an
Android design guideline,
and a question in is,
is there any equivalents
for material design on the web?
HIREN PATEL: Not that
I have come across.
I'm not sure if any of
the other GDEs are aware.
I would think that a lot of the
guidance offered over the UI
within Android
might be applicable
as well for mobile, especially
for mobile use cases.
The design language is
pretty much the same,
so I would go with
that for starters.
JOHANN DU TOIT: Thank you.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: OK.
So thank you Dale and
Johann for helping us
in moderating the questions
and answering them.
And also Hiren,
for the nice job.
Now we will move to
Dale, who will spotlight
a couple of local events, and
the cool stuff that the GDE
program has been working on, and
so I'll let Dale tell you more.
DALE HUMBY: Hey, everyone.
A few weeks ago, we had
the Google Developer Summit
in Africa, and that was held
in three cities-- in Lagos
on the 19th of August,
in Nairobi on the 22nd,
and in Cape Town on
the 25th of August.
And this was an event
hosted by Google,
and a lot of the Google
developer experts
from around Africa.
It was a two track
conference over one day,
and the first track was focused
on material design for Android,
and the second track
was cloud and web track.
And, you know, for me, I
attended the cloud and web
track, being a cloud
GDE, and I think
one of the-- what was made
really exciting for me was
that most people in Africa,
they access their internet
through the phones, or
through their cell phones,
and it's a barrier to entry,
having to download and install
applications if you're
an app developer,
and so having really great
mobile web apps on your phone
is-- well, being able to attract
an audience on that is good,
because it means you
don't have to worry
about doing the installation.
And these two talks
focused on new tools
for web developers, which bring
web app functionality closer
to that of mobile applications.
The first talk was on push
notifications for Chrome,
and this allows web apps to send
notifications-- or a website
to send notifications-- down
to the website on your Chrome
browser, just as, as it were,
like on the Android devices,
like native Android
push notifications.
The second talk was on
offline page caching,
which is one of my favorite
technologies at the moment.
This allows your web
app to cache data
so it can still work even
when the app's offline,
and then synchronize when
you get your connection back,
and that could be because
you choose to switch off
your data because
you're roaming,
or it could be because you're
just on a poor data connection.
So those are the two talks
that I attended while there,
and if you would like a
summit-- a Google summit--
to come to one of your cities,
please post on the Google+
page, and we'll also be
putting up links to the slides
and the code labs that we
had, so you guys can do them
yourselves.
KENNETH KINJANJUI: Awesome.
Thank you very much, Dale.
Just to add on that,
on the DevFest series,
be aware that you might see
a Google Developer Expert
speaking about the technology
such as service workers,
so you can make sure you
attend one of those sessions.
So right now, this brings
us to the end of this show,
but before that, I would
like to tell you the mediums
that we use to share
our content mostly.
We have the Google Developers
Africa Google+ community,
which can be just found on this
short URL-- g.co/dev/africa--
and that automatically
brings you to the community,
just join it.
GDEs have been always
monitor anything
that comes through
that channel, and also
we post our event links there.
We'll also be posting a
feedback link for this show,
and also we like to hear
good feedback about the show.
Tell us what you
want to improve,
tell us some of the sessions
you like to hear about
from the GDG side.
So thank you very much for
joining us in this show.
See you next month.
Thank you very much.
Bye bye.